en nuestro último vídeo habíamos visto
cómo se podía establecer un precio
razonable para el precio de liquidación
del oro y bueno continuando con esto
aquí restableceremos el precio y digamos
que este sería de mil 150 dólares y que
fuese el precio spot o esencial y que el
prestatario acuerda prestar mil dólares
más su costo de almacenamiento del oro y
el propósito de este vídeo es que se vea
como hay un precio como límite inferior
para que llegue a la máxima baja ya
habíamos establecido un precio de 1150
pero imaginemos ahora desde un punto de
vista de alguien que quiere comprarlo
dentro de un año el oro entonces
pongamos que eran de 1050 dólares y
digamos que 3 dicha persona que estás
interesado en tener el oro dentro de un
año y en este momento cuentas con mil
dólares que quieres utilizarlos para
obtener el oro pues has querido
comprarlo desde hace tiempo atrás así
que vas a tener dos opciones puedes
comprar el oro ahora mismo y comprarlo
por mil dólares y después si dentro de
un año es el lugar de hace tiempo y
tendrás una onza de oro y un plus
tendrás que pagar también el costo de
almacenaje o la prima por asegurarlo en
algún lugar así que por aquí pondremos
que vas a tener la onza de oro dentro de
un año menos los 50 dólares que hay que
pagar por dicha prestación de
almacenamiento o prima de seguro y otra
forma es que diga hey
estoy poniendo mil dólares ahora mismo
cuando podré tenerlos en algún bono
libre de riesgo y al mismo tiempo
acordarse del comprador dentro de un año
de dicho oro que es cuando me interesa
tenerlo y ahí es cuando me interesa
comprarlo en mil 50 dólares entonces lo
invertimos en el bono libre de riesgo y
así que aquí dentro de un año dos mil
dólares que invertiste en este bono
libre de riesgo habrán generado un 5% de
interés por año por lo que tendrías mil
50 dólares por dichos intereses en tu
bono y luego este dinero lo utilizas
para ir y comprar el oro que estabas
buscando en el precio deseado pues
recuerda que acordarte ser el comprador
en un contrato a término entra entonces
al final obtienes tu oro y si te das
cuenta en damas situaciones termines con
tu onza de oro al final del año cuando
empezaste con solo mil dólares pero
en la situación del bono obtuviste una
onza de oro y no tuviste que pagar por
algún tipo de almacenaje o seguro y en
esta otra tienes que ir pagando por una
prima así que cualquier persona
razonable que está asumiendo que ellos
están comprando el oro para un término
largo el hecho es que les gustaría que
en cualquier situación se ahorrarán 50
dólares en el transcurso del año
entonces ya analizando las cosas pues
obviamente tú también preferirías
invertir tus mil dólares en un bono
libre de riesgo porque esto finalmente
te va a dar un poco más de ganancia y no
tendrás que estar pagando por algún tipo
de almacenaje que es molesto estar
previendo y bueno justo aquí estos 50
dólares que estoy en un ciento que es el
precio actual les voy a referir que
imagínate que todas las demás personas
lo hubieran tambien querido comprar o
hacer de esta manera sí que todos lo
hubieran comprado de esta manera con el
contrato a futuro o a término
esto pues demandaría el precio lo que
haría que se elevará
imagínate entonces nadie que resta como
de vendedor lo que haría que el precio
spot aumentara y el otro de demanda
tuviera que bajar y en general sabemos
que este precio debe ser neutral
lo que estos 50 dólares se lavaría más
adelante porque después se convertirían
completamente iguales e irracionalmente
como un bono que nos daría al término de
un precio de 110 dólares en general si
nos regresamos un poco a las tres alzas
del bono el precio spot tendría un plus
más el almacenaje de la prima lo cual
haría que la tasa para pedir dinero
prestado bajará y el bono del precio
spot sería como el plus y bueno la tasa
libre de riesgo respecto al precio del
almacenaje serían como equitativos por
lo que generalmente la diferencia entre
estas alzas y estas bajas del bono son
las tasas estas de aquí la del 10% y la
de 5% pero teóricamente es casi lo mismo
pues el precio racional puede alcanzar a
ser igual
así que si fueran ambas del 10% con esta
tasa el precio del oro sería de 1150 y
si usaran la tasa del 5% el precio
racional del oro estaría en 1100 dólares